the president's remarks come as New York
Governor Democratic Governor Andrew
Cuomo teams up with other Eastern
Governors to coordinate the reopening of
the region and its economy the group
includes New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania Connecticut Massachusetts
Delaware and Rhode Island and the
governor of New York Andrew Cuomo joins
us now from Albany governor good morning
good to be with you good morning so we
just heard President Trump say that it's
his call when states reopen but we know
in fact this falls to Governors so let's
talk about what you're doing with this
coalition I know you're not going into
it blind so talk to us if you could
about the benchmarks that New York State
and yourself have to see met before we
all go back to work and get on with our
lives
my pleasure
first as you as you alluded to the
president's position is just absurd it's
not the law it's not the Constitution we
don't have a king we have a president
and entering this reopening phase if you
will is very very important we've never
been here before
no one has gone through this we need a
public health strategy and an economic
strategy they have to work together and
we have to take one step at a time we've
said we want to do it as a region
because that's how this virus acts
frankly it doesn't stop at a state
border and to come back from this we
should do it regionally and share
information you know nobody knows
everything here so work with New Jersey
work with Connecticut work with
Massachusetts Delaware Rhode Island
let's put the best minds around the
table come up with a regional strategy
and as we start to move forward and
reopen the economy gradually have more
testing so we can see where we're going
and then watch that meter that measures
the number of virus infections spread
every day you tell me the behavior of
people today I will tell you the
hospitalization rate in two days and
Governor she ate that this is uncharted
territory that's absolutely correct and
and you went over some of the benchmarks
there but from a timing perspective I'm
sure even in your own budget projections
you've got to have an idea of when New
York State might be back
- something like normal talked to us
about when this reopening could happen
do you personally plan on going to a
Mets game for example this summer I know
your fan look I will first on sports I
would like to start start watching
sports you know whether or not we sit in
the stadium with thousands of others I
don't know that that is in the short
term for foreseeable future but I don't
know why we can't be watching it on
television right why can't you have
sports games with no audiences and just
to start the the sports and the
entertainment so people have something
and watch and follow but you're talking
months of reentry you're talking of
phased reentry there is no clear
benchmark that you can set obviously
everybody wants to do it tomorrow ASAP
but as you have to calibrate it by
watching the spread of the virus so
start opening the valve people coming
back out and economic activity but while
you're opening the valve watch the
numbers every day of the spread of the
virus you've seen countries reopen too
aggressively the virus came back they
had to close again we don't want to make
that mistake yeah you're right you're
very big on watching the valve but
governor I have to say when I saw your
news conference yesterday with fellow
governors my first thought was rut row
the White House is not gonna like this
did you give them a heads up that you
that you all were planning that we were
governors who were part of it had the
conversation with the White House it's
not partisan Gayle the state of
Massachusetts is part of it that's a
Republican governor this is just common
sense it's just common sense and it's
not no I never thought that it was a
partisan I never thought that but I just
thought the White House has made it
clear who he believes is a leader you're
saying we don't have a king here do you
have to work with the White House in
terms of how you're going to reopen
because he seems to believe that you do
yeah
Gayle first this is a total reversal of
the president's first position right he
has total authority to open up the
economy then why didn't he ever
authority to close the economy why did
he leave it to the states and to the
governor's to close it down why did he
take the position that well it's up to
the states to buy medical equipment etc
it's not my responsibilities or the
states
now this is a total 180 all of a sudden
he's in charge of reopening and by the
way if he wants to do more on the
reopening god bless
I mean nobody this is a daunting task
for anyone you want to figure out how to
do widespread testing which the federal
government should do it but it has to be
cooperative and it has to be mutual and
I understand this is a hyper partisan
environment and the president's running
for re-election I don't care I'm going
to work with the federal government
whoever it is hand-in-hand because
that's in the best interest of the
people of my state and nobody can do
this alone because nobody's done it
before governor as we consider the
variables necessary to reopen the
economy here in New York I think it's
worth looking back at the conditions the
closure in the first place on March 2nd
you were on this program and you urge
calm there was one case at the time and
zero fatalities by the end of the month
there were a thousand there were 60,000
cases and a thousand fatalities but the
closure of essential businesses didn't
come until the 22nd of March quite late
in the scheme of things looking back do
you wish you had closed things down
sooner do you have regrets and would
that have lowered the death toll yeah I
think it's the exact opposite factually
I don't think you'll find another state
that moved faster than New York just
look at the dates you did from March 1st
to let's call it March 20th we went from
basically one or two cases to total
closure in like nineteen days think
about that you closed that with total
closure in 19 days schools closed
businesses closed only essential workers
that nobody moved that fast
and in that process communicate with the
people of New York good well I was gonna
say the question is not whether you move
swiftly just in your mind I know this is
heavy this weighs heavily on your
conscience do you wish in retrospect
with hindsight being 20/20 that you had
closed things down sooner former CDC
director Tom Frieden said 80% reduction
in fatalities if the closure had come
just a week or two earlier so I'm asking
you for a bit of reflection yeah
well first of all who knows if he's
right or if he's wrong right Monday
morning quarterbacking is a little
premature
especially when the game is still being
played but I think does everybody if you
could replay the tape yeah I want to
know where we were in December as a
nation where were we in January as a
nation where were we when we saw these
cases in China developing didn't we
think somebody would get on a plane in
China and bring it here that's judge
January that's February that's March
that's this nation that's this White
House that's every state so yeah if you
could replay the tape everybody would do
it differently every every public health
expert every editorial board every media
outlet every government official would
do it differently but no state moved
faster than New York factually all right
Governor Cuomo thank you very much we
look forward to continuing to cover
these next moves as the state of New
York and the region considers reopening
for business governor thank you very
much